Слава Україні, слава Умань, слава Рабі Нахман!
Хасиди готуються зустрічати юдейський Новий рік в Умані.
Співаємо, танцюємо, читаємо молитви.
Це вау - приїхати сюди!
Він з Бразилії. Він з Франції. Слава Україні!
Тут похований цадик, тобто праведник хасидів - Рабі Нахман.
Без Рабі Нахмана ми не можемо почати Новий рік.
Він наш заступник на небі. Цього вечора починається Рош га-Шана,
три книги Біблії відкриваються на небі.
Ми житимемо чи помремо? Будемо бідними чи багатими?
Щасливими чи сумними? Там це написано.
Попри заклики української та ізраїльської влади утриматися
від поїздок в Україну на Черкащину прибули понад 35 тисяч хасидів.
Востаннє стільки паломників тут було до пандемії коронавірусу.
- Вам страшно було приїхати сюди?
- Ні, мені було страшно не приїхати сюди.
- Що ви робитимете, якщо почуєте сигнал повітряної тривоги?
- Найперше, молитимемося Богу, щоб він нас захистив.
Ми віримо в Бога, це наша надія. Лише Бог, він може все.
- А як щодо протиповітряної оборони? - ППО - теж Бог.
Хто контролює світ? Хто контролює ППО, вас, мене? Лише Бог.
Здебільшого повітряну тривогу хасиди ігнорують.
Міська влада визнає, що достатньої кількості укриттів в Умані немає.
У кварталі паломників одне зі сховищ має ось такий вигляд.
Це підвал поруч із головною святинею - могилою Рабі Нахмана.
Тут паломники моляться, іноді - під музику.
Надвечір, коли заходить сонце і незабаром зійде перша зірка,
починається Шабат і незабаром розпочнеться власне святкування
Рош га-Шана - Нового року.
Паломники вже виходять на вулиці, починають співати,
танцювати і молитися. Вони вдягають свій найкращий одяг
- білого кольору. Тому що він символізує чистоту.
Адже Новий рік потрібно зустрічати чистим.
Щоб Новий рік був справді "чистим", готуються і комунальники.
Ви знаєте, я вже звикла, я на це дивлюся…
Там зібрала, сюди вивезла, висипала. А що робити?
Щоб на завтра було легше.
Ввечері вивезуть, зараз машина буде.
Ну, воно кожен день таке, воно кожен день таке…
Комендантська година святкування у хасидському кварталі
не зупиняє попри зусилля поліції.
У кварталі паломництва діє низка обмежень:
тут заборонений продаж алкоголю і піротехніки, посилено чергують поліція:
і українська, і ізраїльська.
Поліція напередодні проводила роз'яснювальну роботу
і зустрічі із равинами, які і доносили інформацію
до паломників про те, що в разі, коли звучить повітряна тривога,
то їм, звичайно, потрібно прямувати до укриття.
А окрім того, наголошувалися на дотриманні правил
комендантської години, яка в нас розпочинається з 00.00
і триває до 4 години ранку і ще доносилась інформація
за окремими тими обмеженнями і заборонами, які є в місті Умані.
Та хасиди живуть за своїми правилами.
Наприклад, багатьох не турбує, що доводиться жити разом
з десятьма людьми в одній квартирі.
Як дорого коштує винайняти кімнату?
- У шекелях - не знаю скільки в гривнях - 2400 шекелів за кімнату
на кілька днів. - Скільки людей у кімнаті?
- П'ятеро. - Не тісно? - Не так і погано. У нас хороша кімната.
Багато кімнат ще менші. Люди приїздять з усього світу,
живуть у маленьких кімнатах і платять багато грошей,
лише аби провести час біля могили святої людини.
Місце, щоб переночувати коштує від двохсот доларів.
Якщо ночуєш у кращому місці, в готелі - тисячу-дві тисячі доларів.
- За ніч? - Ні, за весь тиждень.
Що далі від центру хасидського кварталу - то дешевше.
- Ви тут здаєте житло? - Так. - А скільки до вас заїхали людей?
- Шестеро. - Шестеро людей, а звідки? - Ізраїль.
- А не секрет, по чому, які ціни? - Ну, в мене, наприклад, вийшло по 120.
А взагалі більше, буває, беруть. Бо я наперед домовлялася,
не знала цін. - 120 доларів? - Так. За весь період.
А ось - найдешевший варіант для великої родини.
Головне - поруч із могилою Рабі Нахмана.
Рабі Нахман. Могила - хороший-хороший.
Паломники в Шабат не можуть пересуватися автомобільним
транспортом, тобто вони, на жаль, не можуть проживати дуже далеко
від зони паломництва. Вони обирають проживати,
наскільки це можливо, близько до могили.
Саме тому, можливо, це також є причиною,
чому вони обирають оселитися, може, не в дуже гарних умовах,
однак поруч з могилою Рабі Нахмана.
Більшість готелів у хасидському кварталі побудовані незаконно.
Отримавши дозвіл на триповерхову споруду, забудовники
зводять по дев'ять поверхів. Офіційних готелів тут - три-чотири.
Решта - не платять туристичний збір.
Саме тому, як пояснюють у міськраді, в Умані запровадили
податок на кожного паломника. Цього року він складає
335 гривень з людини на добу. Сплачувати його готові не всі.
Це типу жарт зараз, що євреї люблять гроші.
Але тут ми бачимо, що всі люблять гроші. Для мене це дивно.
Бо якщо ти тонеш, ти мав би цілувати руку, яку тобі простягають
для допомоги. Ізраїльтяни приїжджають в Україну,
варто бути більш гостинними.
Це здирництво! Кажи, як є! Це здирництво.
- А ви заплатили ці гроші? - Я не можу сказати, бо тут поліція поруч,
але… Ні, не заплатив. Але, думаю, більшість заплатили.
В 2022 році, коли започаткували такий туристичний збір,
місто отримувало близько 10 мільйонів. Хотів би зазначити,
що в цьому році ми запровадили ще один такий інноваційний
туристичний збір - це онлайн-сплата туристичного збору.
Орієнтовна сума на сьогоднішній день, що мені відомо,
це близько 17-18 мільйонів у бюджет. За ці кошти в цьому році…
Ми однозначно плануємо витратити їх на наші лікарні частково,
а іншу частину ми витратимо на Збройні сили України,
на допомогу нашим військовим.
Період паломництва на могилу цадика Рабі Нахмана
- це й заробіток для деяких уманчан.
Сантехнік Олег протягом місяця може заробити 20 тисяч гривень,
тоді як його звична ставка - 12 тисяч.
Просто, що вони відносяться погано до всього.
Кидають багато вологих серветок. Забивається каналізація.
Ну, в Ізраїлі, може, інша якась. А тут... Тут вічна проблема.
Тут мережі старі, все старе. Коли будують ці будинки, вони повинні
розраховувати, в два-три рази збільшувати можливість цих труб...
Дуже великий наплив людей. Через це ці всі проблеми.
Ірина восьмий рік на Рош га-Шана.
Протягом минулих років вона працювала на хасидській кухні.
На сьогоднішній день була ціна 50 гривень в годину.
Хоч іди, працюй, хоч не іди, не працюй. І в Рош га-Шана вони
піднімають, тобто, якщо вони платили тобі до цього 50 гривень,
максимально ти можеш вибити 70 гривень, і це буде просто твоя стеля.
Нині Ірина торгує в крамниці у кварталі хасидів,
адже тут потрібна була продавчиня.
Утім наступного року жінка готова повернутися на хасидську кухню
попри специфічні умови роботи.
Почистити, нарізати, принести, помогти.
Українці не можуть готувати, тому що це… Якщо хлопці, то, так,
вони їх допускають до приготування їжі, а жінок - ні.
- Ви ж так працювали, як вам взагалі там працювалося,
як ставилися до вас? - По-перше, вони сильно хамлять.
Я не з тих людей, що будуть мовчати. Я зразу поясню,
що я можу двинути. Мені абсолютно все одно. Українок вони бояться.
Якщо ти показуєш, що ні, ти мені сюди не сядеш,
я тебе швиденько скину, вони до тебе тоді ставляться з повагою.
Поки їхні жінки вдома, хасиди святкують.
Деякі моляться за Україну. На святі не відчувається напруги.
Віталій Камозін, представник Об'єднаної єврейської общини,
відзначає: українці навчаються жити з паломниками мирно.
В цьому році взагалі рівень організації паломництва
дуже високий відносно минулих років.
І в цьому році був лише один випадок антисемітизму
в соціальних мережах, але і на той поліція дуже сильно зреагувала,
оперативно. Наприклад, у 2020 році, я пам'ятаю, що тут були і побої,
і ножові, і так далі. В цьому році все дуже спокійно.
Я знаю, деякі люди виглядають дивно, незвично їх бачити.
Ми бачимо людей, які виглядають по-іншому й іноді це нас лякає.
Але під цими костюмами - звичайні люди. Іноді - божевільні,
особливо люди, які приїжджають в Умань. Треба бути трошки божевільним,
щоб приїхати в Україну в такий час.
Але деякі божевільні люди дійсно хороші.
Рабі Нахман! Умань! Крейзі піпл!